le rsa tout en allant faire les
vendanges un dispositif inédit proposé
dans le haut rhin et dans le bas rhin
cette année un système donc gagnant
gagnant et bénéficiaires sont ravis et
les viticulteurs eux
eh bien ils ont beaucoup moins de mal à
recruter 95 % des postes sont pourvus
cette année du jamais vu
reportage à ribeauvillé de lakes fr et
de bernard jeter mère ça ne saute pas
aux yeux mais david bair beau et maçon
de formation qu'il a perdu son travail
il y a trois ans n'en a pas retrouvé
depuis
pas facile tous les jours mais ce mois
ci il peut cumuler rsa et sont revenus
de vendangeurs forcément ça motive
franchement fait au bénin fois ça fera
du bien au portefeuille
ça vous rapportera combien du coup ce
mois ci jeffrey 900 euros pour trois
semaines de vendanges plus pas loin de
1400 euros donc mais les vendanges c'est
aussi autre chose
la pause de midi l'ambiance ici on forme
une équipe rsa ou pas personne n'est
montrée du doigt
du côté des viticulteurs aussi
d'ailleurs le dispositif arrive à point
nommé
cette année les vendanges sont précoces
et la main d'oeuvre manque à l'appel et
saisonniers sont campés dans d'autres
régions de france où ils sont peut-être
encore en vacances à certains sans
vacances on avait une communauté turquie
sont en vacances maintenant ils sont pas
les petits pas disponible donc voilà il
manque de bras quoi et donc pouvoir
faire appeler les gens qui bénéficient
du rsa bien sûr c'est super du gagnant
gagnant mais pas une fin en soi pour le
conseil départemental du haut-rhin à
l'initiative du dispositif ce dernier
doit être un outil de plus pour le
retour à l'emploi
le département veut confirmer les
résultats de ces dernières années
en deux ans ce sont 15 % de
bénéficiaires du rsa 15%
ça veut dire plus de 3000 personnes qui
ont trouvé un emploi de plus ça veut
dire en contrat de plus de quatre mois
ou une formation professionnelle
qualifiante
le nombre de ceux qui cumulent vendanger
rsa n'est pas encore connue mais le
département envisage déjà d'élargir le
dispositif
d'autres secteurs comme l'hôtellerie ou
la restauration